hey what's going on you guys Friday
[__] night it's so bright yeah we
were filming I'm getting this [__] right
we were filming porn Here ear that's why
yeah I was having [__] technical
issues and [__] I was getting rushed and
everything I did Rush you I felt like I
was kind of getting rushed that was your
perception and every time I was getting
ready to jump I was pretty cool with
about I thought on what happened and
then like uh we'll do it again you worry
about it too much we got some yeah we
got we we got we got some
footage probably about 10 minutes of it
probably yeah something like that yeah
the opening of it was pretty good
actually yeah I thought I thought it was
good yeah yeah yeah we were trying to
film some [__] but you know yeah I feel
like it's too bright is it too bright
yeah might I'll bring it down little
maybe CU I pushed it up well yeah that
that light's super bright over there
yeah kind of what's up Oracle what's up
Sebastian what's up Zach what's up sad
everybody's here yeah we're gonna go out
tonight we're going yeah we're going to
uh mannequins tonight so we'll see how
oh no that's the one this is the one
right that's yeah that's okay all right
there we go that's a little bit better
all right I don't like all that bright
[__] in my face um Sebastian said it's
minus five here oh [__] it's so you have
actual winner yeah wow it gets cold here
it's 70° f
okay I will say on Wednesday night when
we when we streamed last it was 49
degrees that's Fahrenheit in case you're
not in the US 49 degrees which is pretty
cold for Florida it's not that cold I I
know but for Florida that's pretty cold
however today the high I believe was 83
mhm and I think the low tonight cuz I
looked because it's like if we're going
to mannequins tonight I was just kind of
like what's the temperature going to be
can I wear long sleeves or something
like that no I cannot the low tonight is
69°
that's as cold as it's getting what's up
sad s's in there been talking to sad off
and on all day to day talking about
history the American
history especially the War Between the
States you find that very
fascinating yeah I guess they don't
really teach much of that in other
countries they don't teach that much
here anymore I mean well why little well
the thing about it is like why would
they in other countries because they got
their own [__] history actually you
know who I heard the biggest students of
the biggest fans of that war was I don't
know if it's I don't know if it's passed
down through the generations but
Japanese Boomers loved that story that
makes sense they they would like they
would they'd had reenactments they study
it and everything uh play uh war games
on tables you know reenacting the or
replaying the Battle of Bull Run on a
damn on on a remember the old game
tables you used to have it was like
topographical tables and they'd had
painted lead men and everything they'd
do
that Zach says I had a hookup arranged
but his car wouldn't start so blue balls
for me tonight not for you guys though
no
never pretty much never right man I
thought you gay guys had had it easy
just hook up you know well I guess I'm G
to go down to the bath house and just
you know lay up around these like when
you when you have something set up and
you're like well that didn't work out
well [__] it I'll just go and find some
place just go to the bath house lay
around jerk each other
off it's all men here it's okay he could
do that kind of [__] yeah yeah it' be
kind of cool it would be kind of cool
yeah it'd be a lot easier it' just be a
lot easier yeah but I've well you have
it easy I'm here all the time I know the
thing is though is you know uh having
gay having gay friends and [__] like
Toby it's not easy it's harder for them
they never can find the guys they're
looking for there's not enough of them
well that's what I mean it's like it's
it's it's a smaller pool to draw from a
smaller pool yeah so I get it I get
it but still you if they don't fit in
with some the major scene in their area
then they don't fit in you yeah that's
like a that's like two layers of like M
Toby doesn't fit in with the uh Normie
gay scene here he's just too leather
daddy you know so he's he hangs out in
bondage and BDSM type club that
background you know and New Wave stuff
like people that like New Wave Music
he's big into that yeah he loves 80s
[__] well he's already H and under me
he's already and U norie gay just see
him as a freak they're like you know why
are you dressed like that you know
[__] why are you dressed like a
leather daddy well I'm a leather daddy
well because that's what I mean it's
like yeah right norie gay people are
just the same as norie St people yeah
yeah they're always just like what what
is that all
about yeah they're slightly more
understanding I feel but um but yeah you
do still kind of that's why I respect
Toby it's why he's my buddy Cu uh he
wasn't in acceptability and trying to be
it's like way Goths were he liked being
[__] under ground and subversive you
know he does his own thing he's yeah
he's subversive he's subversive gay even
though it does kind of I mean it does
kind of alienate you sometimes like not
as much as it used to I admit um because
you know in the 80s and 90s I feel like
it alienated you more like from normal
society or whatever and like nowadays at
least people kind of get it even if they
don't like it but yeah there's still
there's still a stigma I feel Toby would
tell me some [__] he's like [__] [__]
anybody can be gay now [__] he's like
like that he's like look at them they're
like [__] straight people they're
getting married you know he he'd make
he' kind of would look down his why are
they getting married you know I yeah
I've known a lot of gay guys that were
just kind of like e we don't we don't
want to be like breeders yeah he he
doesn't want anything I get that he
wanted be nothing like I straight people
you know well it's well like I said I
get that because it's kind of like being
like a normie and nobody wants that
right so I mean none of us want that
yeah we're we're in a we're in a sub
culture it's kind of the same thing so
it's like e we don't want to be like
normal people gross so yeah it's so it's
kind of I get it it's why would they
want to adopt
[Applause]
children some people do though it's like
everybody's different like I said but I
can see how yeah you know look what
they're wearing why are they dressed
like that why are they wearing Crocs and
cies for Christ's sake yeah why is he
wearing a polo
shirt why do they look like that you
know he's in all leather and [__] fck
that's what I mean
we like the freaky people I like the
freaky people no matter what sexuality
they are or all sexualities I just like
freaky people we don't care about it
just as long as you're cool yeah long
like I said care we just like freak ass
people I I like normal ass people cuz
some normal ass people but they got cool
normal people but they're weird in other
ways yeah if you if you're normal but
you're tripping out on us then you're
probably going to be all right because a
lot of normal people [__] would would
just like look down you're like what you
know what I mean they and then they
asked somebody many questions that
they're no longer cool we had guys
actually just
Normie I say Normie [__] jock big
jock
corporate yuppies break into the scene
yeah because they were cool his name was
Bill Bill Rivera he was just this big 6
foot2
Alpha C Cuban fidan guy who uh [__]
everybody loved him he was just super
cool and he was banging one of the most
[__] the hottest [__] god chick in
the club you know and he looks
completely completely normal but he was
cool though he's a cool guy yeah like I
said I'm not so much he would just talk
to you he didn't look right I didn't I
didn't have a thing about cuz look
people can look however they want okay
it's just I'm not going to I'm not here
to like [__] on your deal or whatever
but it's just kind of like yeah I'm
going to look a scance yeah if you kind
of come in there like looking like that
but if you just start hanging out and
like talking to people and you're cool
and [__] like that then that's totally
fine the problem I have is like like
people that come in looking like that
and they're like what's this all about
and then they're like asking of course
like you're a [__] ride at Disneyland
or something like piur can I take
pictures with you can can then
post you know and then they try to be
all cool in one
night you know what I mean and break
into the scene in one night no it's
going to take about a year yeah you got
to hang out people are going to have to
[__] know you it's going to take a
while yeah but I think that's why he was
well because he was just kind of he was
just regular he just came in and he just
like acted like he liked the music and
he liked people right he liked us so you
know yeah and he didn't question
anything he just went along with
everything yeah yeah yeah that's another
big thing cuz I feel like never any
questions if you asked him any weird ass
questions like what what is this about
what does this mean yeah why why are
those boots and this the only I'm like I
don't know cuz they look good I don't
just [__] off I you know that just makes
me mad bill was [__] observing what
Bill did for a living is he worked for I
think it was fizer he worked for a drug
company yeah and he sold drugs to
doctors so he had a lot of money and he
didn't throw money around so I respected
him for that he didn't try to buy people
and he didn't like call attention to
himself call what he did right right
like he was just pretty lowkey which and
he was real observant when he wouldn't
ask questions because he he didn't want
to he didn't want to seem uncool which
that's exactly what you should do you
know and one day he said to me he goes
you know I just realize something it's
actually the boots if you got the right
boots you can be goth and I say exactly
ex well gods have known that forever
yeah yeah but it took him a while it's
always that's how you always recognized
a poser was like the shoes that's the
first thing you look at is the shoes cuz
sometimes they get the whole outfit
pretty good but then you look at the
shoes you're like n yeah shoes aren't
right and what he was know know who he
was looking at when he said that Andy ah
right Andy came in and she was just
wearing basically regular clothes black
jeans a T-shirt and her hair and makeup
but she had a [__] badass set of
boots on they were they were either
demonia or new rock yeah and she looked
goth goth as [__] but if she didn't have
those boots on she wouldn't look go she
would have just looked kind of regular
pretty normal right dawned on him he was
he he was wise enough to realize that
that's where the whole look came from
pretty my it's a big part yeah and the
well and she Andy she still comes out
yeah she comes to momento she comes to
mannequins she might be a mannequin s
rusher her and her um fiance whose name
is Vio uh they usually come to
mannequins on Fridays but um she
sometimes like dresses way up sometimes
just kind of you know t-shirt or kind of
thing and black jeans or tight black
pants and something like that but she
always looks like super go she knows how
to do hair and makeup though and
accessories and she's been around
forever so her her credibility is not
questioned she's our age or a little bit
younger maybe my she's my age I think
she okay she's older than I am actually
okay she's older than you wouldn't know
like looking at her but yeah he always
with younger guys and stuff yeah yeah
and like I said she's been with the guys
she's with now they're engaged I think
but yeah Zack said I would go to the
bath house if it wasn't a $40 ride and a
$30 entry fee damn yeah you got to pay a
lot to get into those kind of
places uh Dave is here what's up Dave
going to mannequins tonight but going to
karaoke bar before at 900 p.m. we'll be
there yeah we're going to uh we'll
probably be there at 9:30 10 yeah is
there cover tonight you know yeah cuz
they're doing that Krampus fog party or
whatever I think they're going to like
they're going to make it like even
darker than it normally is which I'm
like oh great because it's usually
pretty dark in there so like people come
in and I'm like yeah who is that you're
just like a shadow you know what I mean
like until but yeah sometimes they do
kind of like events where they turn even
more of the lights off yeah I think
they're kind of hoping that some shit's
going to happen Zach says since Goths
are considered weirdos by normi
standards what's a weirdo by goth
standard
you have to be pretty weird and weird in
a bad way yeah you have to be real
uncool because the thing about it okay
let Let me Give an example there isn't
one goth there's a bunch of substrains
of we all know in in generation how old
you are has a lot to do with it yeah
that too uh but we recognize all that
and some of the young kids man are
[__] fantastic God they look so good
they look so [__] good they we were
talking about the other night it's like
man if we' had that [__] when when back
in the 80s yeah
like what okay she's running it's okay
it's just a it's just a bamb it's all
right they're not they're not coming to
get you yeah Bambi's like [__] that I'm
out of here oh we got some money oh
thank you Jeffy art hey what's up Jeffy
I work security at the Eagle in Wilton
Manners in my experience the leather and
rubber fetish people are way more civil
awesome and interesting to talk to than
the so-called gay normies yeah normes
are you wouldn't think this because I
think people still maybe not as much as
in the past but they used to have a
perception that's like oh all this
weirdos and they're going to cause all
this trouble and not at all no those are
the easiest ones to deal with yeah and
we've heard that from every single club
owner Club manager we've ever known it's
like the goth Knights are the best
nights everyone's super nice everyone's
super chill everybody tips um you know
what I mean there's no drama there's no
fights there's no anything like that you
have like Normie places and it's just
kind of like they're pulling people out
of there all the time they don't know
how to act they don't have a club
culture that's what I mean they don't
have club culture that's what I mean and
you know [__] edgy gay and edgy
straight seeds have a club culture and
there's a lot of crossover a really
edgy I say straight club has a lot of
gays in it and a lot of bisexuals in it
there's no distinction like you know I
would call The Goth scene basically a
straight scene but there's so much
crossover there's gays in there there's
lesbians there's bisexual stuff trans
people
but it's you don't notice it it it
Blends in so well you're just kind of
like you're like yeah and you know them
right so you
know that you don't really notice it you
kind of experience it Without Really
noting
it and it's also a lot of different
races of people you got black people in
there that just fit right in they've
been part of the scene forever you know
black DJs and the Hispanic people are in
this state they're they're basically
indistinguishable from white people
because we've been in this state
together for hundreds of years and uh
I'll be talking to somebody and then
realize you know what she's Hispanic I
never realized that you know yeah it
doesn't really age because you don't
really it doesn't really well like I
said everybody everybody's everybody's
go and that's just kind of part of the
same thing so it's like it never really
like occurs to you that it's like they
might be a different ethnic group like a
different ethnic group or a different
like you know sexual orientation or
whatever you just don't like really we
all like the same music you're just like
B I like the same music the same fashion
same aesthetic we know the same stuff
watch the same movies type of stuff yeah
so it's all kind of like so that's why
that's one of the things that I think
attracted it me too like back in the day
yeah but we were just
amazed how good some of the young people
look and the clothes that they have yeah
cuz at mannequins they do like there's
like these are kids in they're like
eight from like 18 to 25 something like
that yeah and they do and they organize
this themselves the club didn't do this
they do something called a baby bat
Invasion and these are like I said kids
but they show up and they're [__]
they look man they look fantastic
they're just like all [__] death Rock
they look like old [__] school yeah
except if old school 80s if we had had
money if we had money and access to the
[__] that they have nowadays and if
compan made the [__] they look like we
wished we would have looked back then
but we didn't have the [__] they look
like the way a [__] Rich rock star
would have looked or a rich artist would
have looked in the scene back in like 83
like they were a
yeah but it's like an 18-year-old kid
and they know all the bands they know
all the old bands they all the [__]
they're not posing they actually know
all the [__] they know the members of
the well you show you showed me that
like that Instagram was it an Instagram
reel or something like that like with
that girl I don't know how old she was
but you were like you gave me your
headphone and you were like what song is
that yeah yeah that and I was like
that's Cinema strange yeah it was clumsy
suck ofus holy crap she's one of them
who are they're not old they they formed
in the early
2000s but still they're still fairly
obscure even in the goth scene because
they're more death Rocky you know what I
mean so I was like actually surprised I
was like wow that's pretty cool you guys
a good youngster a good youngster okay
yeah Dave says gotta go see you there
yeah we'll be there absolutely I'm kind
of out of looking forward to it I
haven't been in a while actually momento
is next Friday I
think Victor says I'm 100% straight but
I enjoy sleep sing with
men I love that Allison says Tom that's
like New York with the whites and
Hispanics yeah and especially down here
and I'm sure it's like even more
pronounced in South Florida um but even
up here it's just kind of like nobody
notices nobody really notices
honestly we're all listening to the same
music and we're all wearing the same
clothes and nobody has any accents or
anything it's we're all a part of the
same tribe you know that's kind of what
it is but U we kind of got off on the I
want to answer the questions that's what
the new youngsters look like they look
ftic Fu fantastic I wish I'd looked like
that in the holy crap I couldn't afford
all that stuff I didn't know how to do
makeup back then I didn't have YouTube
tutorials like to show me how to do
[__] makeup and stuff man they're so
lucky yep they have all the a lot harder
they can get their hands on all the gear
yeah they can get like all these cool
clothes like I said they can do like
tutorials online and like show them how
to do it like without [__] it up and
and like I said they're not they're not
posing they know all the music yeah and
it's well what I always thought was kind
of cool like you know um because we have
a friend named Nick who's maybe 21 or
something like that and he is super into
like the old
[__] and that's kind of how we met him